hey 42 here we like to define things by
their age and sometimes it's a very
important piece of information
especially when it comes to stuff like
dating safety equipment or that jar at
the back of your fridge
don't hoping that you will regret it
when it comes to estimating the age of a
person we mainly go on their appearance
but when it comes to ideas products or
technology then we often think about
things associated with them for instance
you would think of video games company
would have started no more than 50 years
ago because of how new the industry is
but this doesn't always work so today
just like that time we swiped right on
your friends grandma we're looking at
things much older than you expected
[Music]
Mario link Donkey Kong Samus Aran these
are the names of some of the greatest
video game characters of all time as
well as many pets and probably a few
unfortunate children whose parents
thought they would be cool names as one
of the very earliest video game
companies obviously you know that
Nintendo has been around for a fair
while but very surprisingly
they were founded in 1889 that's right a
video games company was founded over 120
years ago obviously there was no
personal computing back then there
weren't even TV screens so is mario
based on a real-life game where men
dressed up as plumbers and would crush
Turtles
well Nintendo actually started out as a
playing card company set up by fusa Jiro
Yamaguchi in fact they are still making
playing cards today
in 1956 Hiroshi Yamauchi the grandson of
the founder went to visit the United
States playing card company he saw that
despite them being the biggest card
company in the world they were still in
just a tiny office this didn't fit the
grand ambitions he had for Nintendo he
tried out many ventures and over the
following years
Nintendo ran a taxi company a TV network
a food brand and beef in a series of
love hotels so Zelda could have been a
type of rice and perfect dark could have
been a very gloomy erotic pen
house but it was Nintendo shift to toys
in 1966 that got them where they are
today they saw the potential of the
light gun and how people could interact
with a screen this led to the handheld
game and watch series and then in 1983
the Famicom and nez interestingly Mario
was actually named after Mario Segale
the landlord of the American Nintendo
office who allegedly let them pay their
rent late when they were struggling he
also ate magic mushrooms and saved the
princess from a giant evil turtle but
that's probably just a coincidence
emoticons are so common that your mom is
likely to just text you chicken legs
snowflake angry face when she's mad that
your dinner is getting cold but the
first emoticons are over 150 years old
Morse code had its own form of
abbreviation with certain numbers being
given a meaning so as to save on
unnecessary tapping time one was wait a
minute 13 was I don't understand and 22
was love and kisses although this became
88 at some point later on maybe we
needed four times as much loving kisses
in the world these aren't really
emoticons Oh a transcript of an Abraham
Lincoln speech in The New York Times
from 1862 contains the lie applause and
laughter wink like an inside joke for
Lincoln there is some debate and whether
this was intentional or just a typo
there was no autocorrect in the time of
abracadabra Lincoln so there could have
been a lot of Milkshakes in his spleen I
mean mistakes in his speech there is no
doubt about the emoticons in book
magazine in 1881 though since they are
clearly labeled these may have be the
first documented emoticons Scott Fahlman
an early computer scientist is credited
as creating the happy and sad emoticons
that we know today since he described
them on a message board on 19th of
September 1982 the smiley was to
indicate jokes but he also mentioned it
is probably more economical to mark
things that are not jokes given current
trends Jesus a laugh a minute down in I
T apparently paperwork used to be a very
difficult
thing to get to people before the world
went digital and if he wanted something
faster than relying on the postman then
you turn to the fax machine through the
80s and 90s factors really your only
option to send reports contracts and
defensive doodles of your boss across
the country in an instant although it
wasn't until the mid-60s that commercial
machines came onto the market the first
ever fax machine was made all the way
back in 1843 over 30 years before the
telephone and like Alexander Graham Bell
it was another Scotsman Alexander Bain
who invented the fax machine perhaps
there is something about the cold gray
Scottish climate that made them find any
way possible to avoid leaving the house
the first commercial service was with
Giovanni casella's pan Telegraph senders
would use non-conducting in in write on
a sheet of tin a metal stylus would move
across the sheet and would register the
current which would cut out every time
it passed over the ink the pattern of
this electrical current was then sent by
a telegram and the machine on the other
end would print it out by using paper
soaked in chemicals which would react
and stain the page when a current passed
through it the biggest difficulty was
syncing up the machines so they used
large heavy pendulums to stop the
receiving machine from only printing the
first half of the document and your
girlfriend receiving a fax saying my
dearest Suzanne I found someone else
yeah good luck explaining to her that it
should have ended with to fix the leak
on my roof modern communication has made
a lot of old tech redundant and the
language inform is constantly changing
but asked of the emoticons some of the
things that we associate solely with
internet culture actually predated by
quite some time and that is very true of
the at symbol the earliest record we
have of it is from 1345 in a Bulgarian
translation of a Greek Chronicle but its
usage was relatively commonplace when
recording trade one theory is that it
started as an a inside an e to denote
each art rather than just at if you
wrote ten apples at two dollars it might
be confusing whether it was two dollars
for all of them or
each ie $20 in total this symbol could
have been used to avoid that confusion
but others think it was for months
writing the Latin ad a common word since
they were always looking to abbreviate
to save on ink and time as everything
was done by hand
it was also commonly used in Spain and
Portugal from the 16th century to mean a
roba a unit of weight these days many
languages have a different nickname for
it
the koreans call it snail the danish
call it elephant's trunk the Slovaks
call it pickled herring and the dot
sometimes call it little monkeys
testicle you do not want to see Holland
browsing history many great linguists
have come from the second oldest
university in the world the University
of Oxford it has been around in some
form since 1096
that's only thirty years after the
Battle of Hastings in 1066 you know the
only dates you can actually remember
from history class and here's a fact
that will destroy everything you thought
you knew about history
Oxford University is actually older than
the Aztec empire which began in 1325
only the University of Bologna has
existed for longer being founded in 1088
all over la Nia is older Oxford is
surely the more famous and name that is
respected around the globe it's alumni
include Sir Walter Raleigh who led a lot
of English colonization of North America
the great architect Sir Christopher Wren
actor Emma Watson that bloke who created
the Internet Sir Tim berners-lee and
offers junior Tolkien Lewis Carroll
Oscar Wilde CS Lewis and dr. Seuss now
here's a snack that is far older than
you'd expect and I'm not talking about
that exam which that you bought in a
moment of madness and the gas station
it's popcorn corn was domesticated in
Mexico some 9,000 years ago and we have
found evidence of popcorn that is 5,600
years old made by Native Americans down
in New Mexico so it's a true American
classic the oldest existing snack brand
in the states is baker's chocolate
founded by John Hannon and dr. James
Baker in
1964 it was originally called Holland's
best chocolate but when Hanlon
disappeared on a sailing trip in 1779
the Baker took his chance after all life
is like a box of chocolates you eat them
all yourself as soon as you get the
opportunity and our final item also
comes from an old snack spa but we're
not talking about that disgusting
precooked canned meat that became
popular in the post-war period no we're
talking about the never-ending stream of
annoying messages it's no coincidence
that they share the same name though the
idea comes from an old Monty Python
sketch in a cafe where nearly every item
on the menu includes spam with some
baked beans thrown in there somewhere
when early internet chattering was began
some users would repeatedly type spam in
order to shift a line of text off screen
since you wouldn't have the ability to
scroll through conversations like we do
now so it became the common word for
sending out unwanted messages too many
people with no forrester who would be
reading them but this concept was not
unique to the world of the Internet in
1864 many British politicians were
deeply irritated at a telegram that many
of them receives a message from meses
Gabriel of 27 Harley Street that gave
the opening times if their dental
practice hoping for more business but
none of them would bite and we've not
smiled kindly on spam ever since that's
about it for today I need to go now as I
must reply to mr. Jack Ondes email he
saves there's six million dollars
waiting for me in a trust account and
all he needs for me to release the funds
is a small deposit at 1% I can't miss
this opportunity thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2 there are
hidden oil wells all over Los Angeles
these secret oil wells are hidden right
in plain sight somewhere next to schools
and shopping malls he had simply gotten
drunk at a local pub and was walking
home past a palace at 7 a.m. when he
decided to go for a stroll through the
halls of possibly the world's most
famous residence